okay [ __ ] we're back we're going to
go to a message from Michael up box box
box box and that were driving school
brothers okay your brothers and sisters
Harley's I'm to talk much game because
talking which concession all of them
together missing
[Music]
why
[Applause]
know what [ __ ] it
guys are up GPS on you well it hold us
in right
there we go
well I'll talk to Ruth pop it out
holy
backhand
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] no I'm gonna need a new
car this [ __ ] is broke
but I thought
there we go thank you get by your
service sir
[Music]
hey
okay chef's this is dangerous never do
what I just didn't realize guys did not
make a u-turn seven playing highway
because simple as that
okay now I got to make another user
remember kids out there this in real
life
the [ __ ]
they're not there that ever I life
what's up tires were
okay this cars bought this house and
what am I going to do
just a lot more thank you
all right now five-on-three [ __ ]
gay bar yeah the source be hot
Oh make no [ __ ] see
yes I [ __ ] up like I already dead
that's where it
cancer
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
alright ago and then go in here again I
guess
where's that yellow [ __ ] what's the [ __ ]
now to [ __ ] my wife in my old what the
[ __ ] sorry guys one sec it just went to
a pocket full screen real quick
okay hey you got that boom man yeah out
of my way Michael calm down what the
[ __ ] is going on nothing happened it was
a misunderstanding [ __ ] up brick in my
bed [ __ ] it wasn't like that you win
[ __ ] it i'm in this world get this
mother quick she's a cheating [ __ ] no
cal to 10 left guys
mounts my wife what happened with God
gaya paid a teacher tennis in its out
haha that's [ __ ] up man who is soon oh
no back
[Applause]
watch something fail me oh yeah I my
cuckold not enough [ __ ] sleep
oh [ __ ] in it
I could look it
come on you ain't got away yet you're
getting away and I think lost a given
somewhere over the canyon we'll find him
are you kissing was it hard there it
here in my house [ __ ] in my own bed and
if you just acquaintances the old thing
was kind of self-explanatory Frank and
what we're about to do won't need much
contest either she misspoke oh [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
yes
get it turn hey yeah I want to be
sucking up keep your eye on
that's it car right there they'll
freshen up their look oh hey coach doing
all right for yourself yeah hey [ __ ]
he ran off before we can settle our debt
Michael fine you got the call right
there man banging nerd woman's a hobby
not a [ __ ] profession we're gonna
wish it in the back of the truck SATA
cable the world supports up there you
finna pull his deck down and if Rick
fold my marriage down then you really
gonna beat his [ __ ] dramatic tell
whatever I told you a calm possession
but there were a lot of freakin section
fun I'm thinking you were working on
more than just her backhand Mandy's
backhand has come a long way bro but
sometimes it's got to get worse to get
better yeah well maybe I should come up
there practice my backhand on your face
but your negative energy is seriously
bringing me down I hope it is fun we
hooked up man you come into my house
take my money and nail my wife are you
[ __ ] kidding me I'm gonna stick up my
hand and say that was uncool but my bad
seriously how [ __ ] magnanimous metal
of you my applause you [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh and we'll see how you
like when someone [ __ ] with your [ __ ]
oh hey wait you got the wrong idea pal
whoa
let's get this here we go
oh [ __ ]
oh man
yes
are you cool squad yeah come on [ __ ] man
[ __ ] oh we did it [ __ ] his ass yeah
[ __ ] but what we really trying to
pull that do without off the [ __ ]
heels we were trying to teach him a
[ __ ] lesson that was [ __ ] not
absent as best man that was maybe we'll
keep it on the court not in my wife and
you're not taking on housewives back to
that [ __ ] hey it's a service to
the [ __ ] community
that was [ __ ] not
mr. de Santa what the hell that's not my
house oh [ __ ] oh oh I couldn't afford a
place like that I'm inside this coach I
hit balls for a living oh just hiding
there good light green why Martin
Madrazo tibial great Oh geared lady just
[ __ ] terrified whatever it has a
meeting my heart is in me yes you do
something our fridays rock
happy shares the time to you
hey let's go lip leaving behind [ __ ] men
get riddle
put some cattle man
any still let's go back there we divide
up we got resolved
this carton box tops man I can't really
kill much about it I think you slipped a
man all right go back home Wow [ __ ] you
did good I mean I don't know if you hit
anyone cuz your hands all over the place
place I appreciate it back up the car
thank you I didn't it maybe go to a
shooting range to work on your aim we go
out of here [ __ ] man did you close fine
as wine get us not you okay you eat good
yes and I'm cool man I mean you never
mentally oh man I'm [ __ ] X my heart
ain't look like that year oh yes [ __ ]
a Bubba hey you sound kind of men just a
dream they part of missing underworld in
bathroom is your loss pencil trust me we
handled it wherever the [ __ ] Marty
Madrazo is I've known worse we get
handed a few low ranking plan we sit on
it see what happens kid there's no you
second-guessed ha hey thanks for the
help out there today kid the proper idea
was gonna get that hot she pulling
houses off the heel saw show has a weird
way of [ __ ] with people yeah well I
thought I was through with all that [ __ ]
how long what the hell's going on oh
[ __ ] I think about to find up you know I
am do you know who I am do you now are
you you I think so good I know who you
are I know where you live who are you
I'll frankly license
no Franklin maybe he'll mr. de Santa
here Who am I I think Martin madrazo
good boy now maybe give him a little of
the background man mr. madrazo it mr.
madrazo is a legitimate businessman who
was wrongfully accused of running a
mexican-american gang and a narcotic
ring but the charges were dropped
because of the witnesses came up missing
smart go ahead now Michael got a
question for you he do pool and
architectural significance manas would
your home down the hillside invite would
hell I sought the owner was banging my
wife well there was a strange house for
a tennis coach how does it take it
straight clearly yeah well Natalia will
need a hotel while you find out there
revealed once you sure good and I'm
casing here that it there rebuild will
be somewhere in the 2.5 million range of
course great [ __ ]
come on mui never better so what nice
looks like I'm gonna have to postpone my
retirement [ __ ] I'm and I'm mortgaged up
to my eyeballs look I only know one way
to make money I'm gonna have to give an
old friend of call Lester I think he's
in town somewhere let the track him down
give me a little alone time all right go
all right [ __ ] that was a good mission
well thanks for watching y'all hope you
enjoyed it back down